houston we have so many problems we
can't keep track of them that's the new
statement not the old cliche that we've
heard over the years and here's a new
one and i'm a little bit hesitant to go
all in
in response to this news because i
really like josh mccown i think he's a
great person i think he's a greatly
underrated quarterback and i think he
will eventually be a great nfl coach
but the news
that he's been interviewed by the texans
to be their head coach their head coach
with no coaching experience
with no
sign that he's ready to be the head
coach of anything above maybe mid-level
college i mean he's played a long time
great
but
this speaks to and again i say all this
fully aware that josh mccown can end up
being a super bowl winning coach and i
will root for him when he is a head
coach not if but when
but to have it happen now amid all of
the craziness amid all of the
dysfunction amid all of the drama at a
time when everyone around the league is
watching the texans shireen and asking
is there any chance they get it
something like this provides the answer
they don't there is no institutional
self-awareness this is a middle finger
by jack easterby i almost did the actual
gesture this is a middle finger
by jack easterby to the world that we're
gonna do whatever i can convince cal
mcnair to do that's how i read it
well first thank you for not getting us
thrown off the air today and for the
future i appreciate that
second of all i don't know that the
texans know what the texters are doing
mike i i do not think this was for an
actual head coaching job i don't of
course it is the texans but
you've got a game you got to get that
message out there if it's not then you
got to make it clear that he's not being
interviewed for a head coach
no question but i think they're down i
think we're going to see eric the enemy
leslie frazier or matt eberflus get this
job i really believe that and i think
you're going to see josh mccowan get the
quarterback's job i think he and deshaun
watson hit it off and they are falling
behind mike frankly in the in the
coaching search for assistant coaches as
it were because all the other jobs have
been filled and teams have changed
assistant coaches they're moving on and
so i think this was fully to be the
quarterbacks coach of this team i don't
think he's going to be the next norm van
brocklin to go straight from football
into coaching but again mike it's the
texans and they've screwed up pretty
much everything over the last year or a
year and a half or whatever it's been
since they started making trades and
doing dumb stuff and it continues so i
don't know that the texans know what
they're doing mike
nor van broglin the original head coach
of the minnesota vikings and he and fran
tarkinton
hated each other culminating in the
trade that sent targeted to the giants
before he was traded back to the vikings
but look i
okay if hebrewfleus is the guy why not
just hire him the cults are done you can
hire him you don't have to wait the
enemy or fraser you have to wait at at
least until after this weekend if not
two weeks and three days from now the
day after the super bowl but
who's interviewing him if it is be enemy
if it is frasier that's going to get the
job and they're just waiting don't they
understand how stupid it looks that
someone would be interviewing a position
coach without
the future head coach involved this is
al davis later years raiders stuff where
they go out and hire the staff for you
and you just come in
and you take who they give you and it
really neuters the head coach before
he's even walked through the door and
even if he's on board with it it creates
the perception that someone else is
pulling the strings not the head coach
oh i think you're forgetting about
someone mike it was more recent than
that how about jerry jones hiring jason
garrett for an unknown position before
he hired wade phillips and of course
jason garrett was the head coach in
waiting and ended up taking over for
wade phillips so
yes that's exactly what ended up
happening in dallas that's what al davis
has done and i think that's fully what
the texans are doing and so if you're
eric b enemy or leslie frazier do you
say no to this job
well
i i i i guess not because well i think
if you're frasier you don't because
when's the window ever going to be open
for you again right he's been
a former head coach for
six seven years now as long as mike
zimmer's been the coach of the vikings
that's how long it's been since leslie
fraser was a head coach so you got to
take what you can get when you can get
it if you're him if you're the enemy i
think you can still wait i think you can
still wait and the key for the enemy is
i want to know deshawn watson is on
board with me completely and totally
before i would take that job but i just
think that it's a horrible perception
for the texans to interview josh mccown
and not make it clear that it's for
something other than head coaching job
and there's no reason that anyone even
has to know about this it's not like
they had to request permission from some
other team to interview josh mccown and
i don't know how the record keeping
works but i think there's probably a way
to keep it secret that you talk to him
especially if you're not talking to him
about being the head coach of the team
so the whole thing is odd to me and it's
not surprising because these are your
houston texans folks and again i love
josh mccown and i think he'll be a great
coach someday but this is not the ideal
way to enter the nfl as a coach this
idea that they're interviewing as a head
coach when you've never even served as
an assistant coach at any level of
football you've just been a player since
2003 so i don't know where it goes from
here shireen clearly eric the enemy
wants to be a head coach patrick mahomes
echoing today how crazy it is that the
enemy doesn't have a job i just think
this news coming out at a time when
when
everyone is saying what about the enemy
what about the enemy it just makes a
weird situation even weirder
yeah and i hope the texans hire eric the
enemy alex smith said yesterday i think
he called it uh ridiculous and patrick
mahomes today called it crazy and it is
we all thought that eric the enemy was
going to be hired in this cycle and
unless the texans do it he won't be and
he's been passed over and passed over
and passed over and i don't know what
it's going to take for eric b enemy to
get a head coaching job and for those
who say he doesn't
interview well that's all well and good
but you look at some of the head coaches
who have done interviews and we
absolutely know they didn't interview
well that's not why eric b enemy doesn't
have a head coaching job that's not a
good excuse for not having him hired by
somebody at some point over the last
couple years so i really hope mike that
he ends up getting this job in houston i
think the numbers then look better on
minority coaches in this cycle i mean
we've heard a lot about it since the
eagles made their hire but i just think
it's it's better for the team i think
he's going to be a really good head
coach and i think that's probably the
best that the texans can do
in this hiring cycle is hire eric the
enemy i think he'll be a success there
if he gets that chance with deshawn
watson as his quarterback if that
happens
it was fear of imminent litigation filed
by johnny cochran and cyrus mary in 2002
that prompted the nfl to implement the
rooney rule it will take i believe fear
of imminent litigation or reality of
actual litigation to change a situation
that involves teams checking boxes and
complying with the interview requirement
but not actually improving the numbers
there is a point where you don't need a
smoking gun you don't need a donald
sterling tape to prove that there is a
bias that is baked into the cake the
numbers prove it out 70
of the players are black 35 percent of
the assistant coaches are black and the
percentage of head coaches who
ultimately bubble up through the
pipeline and become
in charge of a team is so low the
numbers
scream it out and the more they go
through the motions and ultimately look
there's always going to be a white head
coach who is qualified for every vacancy
there will always be one and there is
always a blackhead coach who is
qualified for every vacancy and it's
like flipping a coin shireen and having
it come up heads over and over and over
and over again there's a point where
it's not coincidence that's what the nfl
is dealing with and the other reality
these billionaires don't like to be told
what to do they don't like us telling
them what to do they don't like fans
telling them what to do they don't like
anyone telling them what to do and i
think there's a certain element of
stubbornness not racial bias just
stubbornness that creeps into it
yeah mike four minority coaches among
the 31 that have head coaches right now
and that's just not good enough it's not
good enough by
any team in this league it's not good
enough by the league and and it needs to
change and you know these incentives
obviously haven't done much to to push
those numbers up and hopefully in the
future in the next hiring cycle and the
one after that we do see uh better
numbers but but i'm disappointed with
with what we've seen
frankly again if the texans hire leslie
frazier eric the enemy i think it looks
much better but if they don't if they
end up with a white head coach here we
go again it's the same thing as we saw
last hiring cycle and the one before
that the one before that
i just wonder how much pressure is going
to be placed on cal mcnair by the league
office and i wonder what will be dangled
we know that stuff happens behind the
curtain will there be a super bowl
awarded to houston at some point down
the road
as the quid pro quo and hey oh that
doesn't happen
oh okay it doesn't happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports